does being around groups of people make
you energetic or does it exhaust you and
if you're the sort of person that you
know will go to a party and interact
with twenty people in you then you have
to go home and be by yourself for like
two weeks
then you're introverted introverts are
exhausted by social interactions
extroverts are the opposite they'll
there they're there they're energized by
social interactions and you know you
might be in the middle so that you can
take it or leave it with regards to
social interactions but you're happy to
go to them and you're happy to spend
time by yourself but a real extrovert
there'll be some of you in here how many
of you can't stand spending time alone
okay so there's only two that will admit
it extroverts are more likely to admit
that sort of thing too by the way but
and how many of you you like to spend
time alone or would rather be alone okay
so there's a preponderance of introverts
in this class as by the by it by all
appearances but that's a really that's a
pretty canonical question for for
extraversion versus introversion it's a
very stable trait by the way it's
manifest itself early in life and it's
it's stable across the age span not
completely introverts can learn to be
extroverted extroverts can learn to
spend time on their own I think that
actually your capacity to expand your
ability past the initial constraints of
your biological temperament is something
like the development of character or
wisdom you know so if you're an
introvert by nature and you learn how to
be extroverted then that expands your
domain of competence and if you're
extroverted you learn to be introverted
the same thing but it's almost like
imagine a distribution of extrovert
introversion here extraversion here a
normal distribution you're set when
you're young it's somewhere along that
distribution with some range around it
and I think what you do as you mature if
you develop your skills as you expand
that range but your set the place at
which you're set doesn't move that much
so ok so there's so you can think about
them as subpersonalities you can think
about them as frames of reference so
frame of reference would be something
like well since you're extroverted you
value being with people and so you're
gonna look at the world for example if
you're extroverted you come into a room
like this you think oh look it's a whole
field of opportunity for social
interactions and if
you're introverted you think well maybe
I'll go set up in the corner and hope
everybody leaves me the hell alone